what is up everybody it's annamac here
for anime uproar and today i will be
discussing one of the biggest twists to
ever happen in black clover although to
be fair all of this was foreshadowed
many chapters ago so if you were paying
close attention to the story you might
have seen it coming after xenon unlocked
a shocking new devil form that
completely changed what we thought we
knew about devil possession yuno just
unlocked a new power that fundamentally
alters our understanding of how magic
works in black clover this is a big deal
and it looks like asta has some serious
competition once again when it comes to
being the most overpowered character if
you enjoyed the blacklover content on
this channel and you want us to keep it
coming you know what to do leave a quick
like and comment it only takes a second
but it helps a lot with the youtube
algorithm and if you're new to anime out
pro or maybe you watch our videos but
you just haven't taken the time to
subscribe yet do me a favor and make
this the video that you subscribe and
hit that notification bell to turn on
all notification you really have to go
through the trouble of subscribing
hitting that bell and then selecting the
option that says all if you don't go
through all of those steps you're still
gonna miss a lot of our videos even if
you are subscribed it's just how youtube
works you can also hit me up on twitter
and instagram at
animeopror finally this video will of
course contain black clover manga
spoilers so please proceed with caution
you have been warned the new chapter
throws us right back into the ongoing
battle between language and finral on
the one hand and xenon in his new devil
form on the other language and finral
are running out of time because langers
can't keep up his spatial magic mana
zone for much longer meanwhile xenon
believes that he has familiarized
himself enough with their movements to
take them down next time they try to
approach him but
langris and finral managed to
outmaneuver xenon by using their unique
spatial magic properties to increase
their speed to absolutely time bending
levels and so instead of going where
xenon thought they would go they
suddenly appear right behind him as they
attempt to destroy his very heart using
spatial magic the chapter suddenly
shifts to yuno the previously
unconscious yuno is finally coming too
and when he awakens he realizes that he
has been knocked into a separate chamber
within the palace this chamber contains
the grimoires of the spain kingdom those
grimoires that still haven't been
claimed by their users once juno finds
his bearings he sees that language and
finral are in big trouble xenon has
already defeated them and he is likely
to kill them within the next few seconds
if yuno doesn't do something immediately
xenon explains to the brothers that not
even spatial magic has the power to
destroy the heart of a devil and he
proceeds to declare victory meanwhile
yuno is going through a personal crisis
as he tries to grapple with the fact
that yet more of his comrades may be
killed right before his eyes he thinks
back to all of his fellow golden dawn
members who were already killed by xenon
and he wonders whether he was wrong to
come on this mission in the first place
yuno wanted so desperately to save his
captain and avenge his fallen comrades
and he trained harder than ever before
in order to get stronger but in this
moment it seems like it was all for
nothing in this moment you know wonders
whether his spot in the infiltration
unit should have gone to someone who was
more worthy than himself yuno then
begins to cry and this is not a man that
we see being emotional very often juno
is known for being calm and stoic nearly
all the time and yet here he is
completely breaking down
ironically in this moment yuno looks
just as sad and desperate as xenon had
looked back when alan died for his
entire life yuna was praised for being
this magical genius he vowed to avenge
his comrades and become the wizard king
so is this really how it was all going
to end yuno remembers the vow that he
made to his rival and best friend osta
and he decides that he cannot give up
now as he summons up the very last of
his power and forces himself to stand up
something insane happens some sort of
entity that looks like a puff of smoke
with eyes and a mouth shows up and says
i am you
but you also have your own power now i
know what you must be thinking you know
either hit his head too hard or he's on
drugs but no this creature is likely a
manifestation of the elf spirit who had
reincarnated inside of juno although i'm
not sure why he would manifest on the
outside instead of just speaking to you
from the inside that said maybe the elf
is not really outside this might just be
how yuno is perceiving the conversation
in his own mind then the puff of smoke
turns into a shiny new spade kingdom
grimoire the spade kingdom grimoire that
prince yuno grinberry all was going to
receive if he had stayed inside the
kingdom suddenly the clouds above the
palace are pierced by a powerful beam of
light and the grin burial supporters on
the outside know right away that it must
be yuno's doing poetry also realizes
that juno's win magic must have come
from his connection to leaked and
tethya's child but his original magic
the magic of the spade kingdom royal
bloodline is light magic or at least it
looks like it might be light magic to me
we don't have direct confirmation yet
but that would make sense since light
magic is considered to be so rare and
powerful and it is also associated with
royalty whatever yuno's original magic
is how freaking crazy is this
development as it turns out yuno has
been using someone else's magic this
entire time the wind magic that he had
been so great with and that he had
practiced using for so long belonged to
leaked and tethya's child not to him as
you will recall tethya had been pregnant
with twins one twin survived but the
other died and was then reincarnated
into yuno's body at the same time as all
those other elves were reincarnated into
the bodies of other humans in the clover
kingdom however because juno's elf was
never even born before the elf massacre
took place living as part of yuno is all
that this elf knows
because of that he feels intrinsically
connected to yuno and that is why he
never tried to take over yuno's body or
force yuno to do evil things to other
humans like all the other elf
reincarnations had done to their human
hosts i have to say that this is a very
interesting twist in the story of yuno's
life and i love how the crazy reveal
about yuno's elf reincarnation from many
chapters ago now became relevant again
in a really cool and consequential way
this new power up for yuno is pretty
freaking broken but it actually makes
sense in terms of the story and it has
been foreshadowed for many chapters
after all if yuno is not from the clover
kingdom and yet he has a clover grimoire
we should have known that something was
up and of course you know is asta's
rival so he has to keep up with him
somehow and after attaining his devil
union mode asta has become more powerful
than ever so yuno had to find some way
to keep pasta on his toes or i should
say tabata had to find a way to keep
yuno and asta close together and that
way was a second grimoire
now armed with two grimoires you know
confronts xenon before xenon has a
chance to finish off langus and finral
euno vows to save everyone including the
entire spade kingdom and to become the
wizard king finally he vows to defeat
xenon even in his new overpowered devil
form and that is how this shocking
chapter ends honestly i'm really excited
to see where this goes next because we
have no idea what someone is powerful
and loved by mana as you know can
accomplish with two grimoires and two
magic attributes and this is not some
artificially created double grimoire
like the one that mars had these are two
top tier grimoires that both really do
belong to yuno so he will be able to
unlock the full potential of both of
them let me know what you guys thought
about this wild twist and let me know
what you guys think is the answer to the
big question what is yuno's original
magic is it light magic is it some sort
of snow or ice type magic because the
spade kingdom is so winter themed or is
it something else altogether personally
i hope it's not just snow or ice because
that would be kind of predictable but if
it were that then combining snow and ice
with wind would mean that yuno would be
able to like control the weather and
create massive storms i mean i guess
that would also be pretty cool even if
it were predictable don't forget to
leave a comment with your guesses or
hopes for what yuno's original magic
will be i'm serious i want everyone to
comment even if it's a meme answer like
drip magic or plot armor magic type it
down right now if you enjoyed this
blacklord video and you want to see more
in the future do me a quick favor and
leave a like and if you're new to the
channel or maybe you watch our videos
but you just haven't taken the time to
subscribe yet make this the video do you
subscribe and hit that notification bell
to turn on all notifications you really
have to go through the trouble of
subscribing hitting the bell and then
selecting that option that says all if
you don't do that you're still gonna
miss a ton of our videos even if you are
subscribed it's just how youtube works
you can also hit me up on twitter and
instagram at anime uproar i want to give
a quick thank you to all of our anime
outpour patrons who make videos like
this one possible special thank you to
alpha sigma this man is an absolute mad
lad and a disciple of lord twigo himself
and i can't forget all of our the one
tier patrons the ones who stand above
all other clans including ingrata pate
heffa algertol hinokamian water the
toasted chi the spike corey mcgowan
kaido might be a gyarados dylan isidor
spidey life tinel tungsten tarkis big
buddhist cody hebert monkey d quilly and
jeremy cummings finally thank you also
to our pro hero tier patrons including
the one and only gilgamesh the red
haired raven angel cruz rathundara very
gucci alicia actor bonnie parks joy and
garcia ted no ted and fat boy games if
you enjoy our videos and you feel that
they provide value to you consider
supporting us on patreon even a single
dollar will give you access to our
patron exclusive discord and your name
will appear in our videos along with
these amazing people as always thank you
guys so much for watching and until next
time see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you